what's up youtubes welcome back to my
channel Richard on data my name is
Richard and this is the channel where I
talk about data so I've talked about the
fact that I work as a data scientist
before and for the overwhelming most
part I find the work to be incredibly
rewarding to be really creative and it's
really something that I have a lot of
fun with except for cleaning data that
part still kind of sucks sometimes it's
also true that the market for data
science is white-hot right now and
there's absolutely no indication that
that's gonna slow down as we move into
2020 and into the next decade having
said all of that I think it's incredibly
safe to assume data science is
absolutely not for everyone and there's
nothing worse than going into a new role
and then realizing it's not for you and
then you have to spend a lot of time and
a lot of energy and there's just tons of
wasted capital that comes with switching
into some different kind of field so I
want to give you five reasons why data
science may possibly not be the career
path that you want to go down in your
individual case and as per my usual
disclaimers these are based on a
combination of my own personal
experience the anecdotes from people
that I still keep in regular contact
with as well as just general research
and observations about the market as a
whole so all I ask is you please watch
this video to the very end to figure out
if data science really is the correct
path for you but then also hit the like
button and hit the subscribe button
because those things also really do help
me out reason number one while you might
not want to actually get into data
science is if you want to come in and
day one and make big huge sweeping
change to your organization so it's
really easy for people especially those
who are coming fresh out of school to
think that you're gonna be running a
bunch of really fancy really sexy
machine learning models and you're
completely gonna come up with this
invention that changes the world it
changes the whole way your company does
business all that kind of jazz
the unfortunate reality of the situation
for the overwhelming majority of people
is that you're not going to spend your
entire day running machine learning
models and building and training and
testing those things even if you do
you're going to get tired of doing that
really quickly trust me on that one
the reality of the situation is that
businesses tend to move very slowly
and there are a lot of reasons for that
first of all if people don't trust a
statistical or machine learning model
they will never change the way that they
do business based on that and there's
just a political reality with most
businesses that there's a lot of people
that need to be involved and need to
sign off on making a decision and that's
doubly true with data science which for
a lot of companies it's a newer field so
it's a lot less established and it's
more difficult to use it in order to
change the way things are done from day
to day having said all of that if your
company is any good and knows what
they're doing they will communicate to
you how you're actually contributing to
the bigger picture and moving the needle
so your work will have an impact it's
just important to ground your
expectation and realize your work will
contribute to moving the needle on
various business decisions but it's
probably not going to be in some big
giant monumental inventive kind of way
reason number two that you might not
want to be a data scientist is if you
want to be a task taker
now some people they just want to show
up to work and get told to do by their
boss and then just go from there and I
completely understand that but if that's
you data science might not be the career
choice for you the reason for that is
data science problems tend to be very
open they're very unstructured clients
and stakeholders and people you're
working with they're looking for you to
come up with a creative solution and to
really get them out of unstructured
chaos so what that often looks like is
you'll have to try a whole different
number of things and you may end up
going down some paths which end up not
working then you have to go back and
redo your work and just live with the
fact that you were wrong about something
even if in the grand scheme of things it
doesn't matter too much and you're
moving in the right direction so you do
have to be very very creative on the
day-to-day so if you just want to be a
code monkey or a test taker you might
want to rethink data science reason
number
three while you might not want to get
into data science and this is highly
related to the last one is if you don't
like working with other people so data
science is an incredibly collaborative
and very multidisciplinary field unless
you're working in the absolute smallest
of startups you're probably going to be
working in a team with other data
analysts other data scientists maybe
people from all kinds of different other
disciplines and skill sets all together
and you have to talk to and communicate
with your clients and your stakeholders
on a frequent basis so if you want to be
just a code monkey who shows up to work
for eight to nine hours a day sits in a
cubicle and writes code I'm not saying
there's anything wrong with that
in fact if that's you go for it but
that's probably not going to be your
experience with data science and you
shouldn't expect it to be reason number
four not to become a data scientist is
if you don't like keeping up with
industry trends so it's become a bit of
a joke in the data science community the
ridiculous number of programming
languages and skills that people are
expected to know and while I think
that's highly exaggerated there's
definitely some element of truth to the
fact that you need to at all times be
aware of the latest and greatest things
that people are working on and
technologies that people are using so
just to give a bit of an example right
now the two biggest juggernauts in
programming languages of data science
are R and Python I don't necessarily see
that changing over the next few years
but it's highly possible that five to
ten years from now there's some
brand-new programming language that
comes around and it just blows R and
Python out of the water and then the
whole industry and market gets on board
with that the earlier that you got
acquainted with whatever language that
is the better because years of learning
and years of experience are incredibly
valuable so if you're somebody who just
wants to be done with learning as soon
as you get out of college you're going
to unfortunately be disappointed in data
science because honestly the learning
only begins once you get out of college
there's all kinds of things that you're
going to learn inside of your job
also with data science in general you do
need to keep some kind of eye on
networking as well as maybe going to
industry conferences just to keep an eye
on the landscape out there and figure
out what other people are doing so you
can stay on top of where the market is
moving the fifth and final reason not to
get into data science is if you hate
either coding or math so this gets back
to the first video I did where I
described that a data scientist is a
jack-of-all-trades who carries a lot of
different skill sets that whole picture
does matter so let's say you're a math
or statistics student you're in school
and you don't necessarily enjoy
programming or coding well unfortunately
that is the reality of most data science
jobs so if you don't like doing that and
don't see yourself doing that every day
you don't want to go into a career where
you might be miserable every single day
and then similarly suppose you're in
software engineering some other capacity
where you're programming a lot but you
don't like statistics or you don't like
math that is going to hold you back in
the long run because anybody can spin up
and prototype a whole bunch of machine
learning models but if you have no
affinity or no knowledge of the
underlying math and statistics there it
is going to hold you back now it's
completely reasonable to be good at or
to enjoy one of these two more than the
other that's totally fine but if you
have a total aversion to one that's
going to end up being a problem so at
the end of the day there is a lot of
hype behind data science right now and
it's completely understandable why
there's a lot of money behind it it's
this brand new thing that's white-hot in
the market all these things but it's
also something which a lot of people
have very unrealistic expectations about
in part that's because of all the
different information about it and job
descriptions of data science which are
broadcast to the world so it is
important that your expectations about
it are somewhat grounded in reality so
if you're comfy with and you understand
the things that I've outlined in this
video again your experience could
very somewhat but as long as you're
aware of these potential realities
you're probably going to be okay and I
think it's going to be just as enjoyable
and experience for you as it has been
for me so thanks for watching this video
until next time richard on data